Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Ça va mes petits choux ?
Pas de panique !
Je parle
à mes légumes.
La version miniature
du chou pommé
ou chou cabus
suivant les appellations régionales.
Lui,
c'est le chou de Bruxelles.
Mais pourquoide Bruxelles
et pas d'ailleurs ?
Parce qu'à l'origine,
ce petit chou vient de Belgique,
du village de Saint-Gilles
situé dans la banlieue de la capitale du royaumebelge.
Mais pourquoi est-il si petit ?
Eh bien au milieu du XVIIème siècle,
l'augmentationde la population dans la métropole
oblige les maraîchers bruxellois à trouver des solutions
pour accroître les rendements
tout en utilisant le moins de terres cultivables possible.
A partir d'une variété que l'on trouve sur la côte Atlantique,
qui pousse
en hauteur
etqui est destiné au bétail,
ils réussissent à force de sélection
à produire dans la banlieuede la capitale belge
une nouvelle variété de choux.
Elle se présente
sous la forme
d'unelongue tige,
d'environ un mètre de hauteur,
d'où surgissent
des bourgeons en forme depetites pommes
d'environ 3 centimètres.
Les belges développent un tel savoir faire surcette variété
qu'ils l'a protègent.
Jusqu'au XIXème siècle,
les agriculteurs français
devaient demander leurs semences
aux grainetiers du roi de Belgique.
Aujourd'hui,
le chou de Bruxelles estcultivé
et apprécié
surtout en Europe du nord.
Et les plus friands
sont nos voisins britanniques
qui le servent lors de leur repas de Noël.
Comme tous les choux à feuilles,
les choux de Bruxellescontiennent des composés soufrés.
Ces composés sont souvent indigestes
et provoquent des flatulences.
Pour les consommer,
il est donc préférable de les faire blanchir,
c'est-à-dire, les faire bouillir5 minutes
dans un grand volume d'eau salée.
Cette première cuisson
permet d'éliminerune partie des composés soufrés
qui vont se dissoudre dans l'eau.
Ensuite,
on les égoutte
eton les fait cuire à la vapeur
ou dorer à la poêle.
En fin de cuisson,
j'y ajoutepersonnellement
un petit filet de vinaigre.
Ça relèvele goût
de ce chou de Bruxelles.
Essayez,
une fois !